السفينه الاولى التي وصلت الى ميناء
اسكندرون في واديها طايب قادمه من
الدوحه تحمل اول دفعه من المساعدات
القطريه البيوت المسبقه صنع القطريه التي
ستقدم الى متضررين الزلزال في تركيا
والشمال السوري هذه السفينه حوت اكثر من
ثلاثه مئه بيت مسبق الصنع كما تشاهدون
بهذا الشكل على ان تصل خمس سفن سفن اخرى
ليصل مجموع السفن التي تصل كدفعه اولى
سبعه سفن ثم اربعه عشر سفينه خلال الايام
المقبله عدد الوحدات السكنيه التي ستصل في
هذه المرحله 4000 وحده على ان يصل مجموع
الوحدات السكنيه التي ستقدمها دوله قطر
الى تركيا 10 الاف وحده سكنيه ستوزع مكتمل
المساعدات القطري تسلم من قبل المساعدات
القطريه الى اداره الكوارث التركيه وايضا
الهلال الاحمر ليتم توزيعها على المتضررين
في الولايات التركيه نسيجه الزلزال اضافه
الى جزء سيخصص للمتضررين في الشمال السوري
عمر الحاج الجزيره من ميناء اسكندرون في
ولايتها تايم